bueno pues la verdad es que es difícil
que una cumbre de siente mal
vladimir putin porque siempre es una
manera de reafirmar la talla mundial de
rusia respecto a la cita que había hoy
las principales expectativas estaban
puestas en las guerras del pasado
digamos los misiles y las guerras del
futuro la ciberseguridad y en ambos
ambos aspectos ha habido algunos avances
aunque tímidos pero sí que apuntan a un
desbloqueo de la situación que ya lo
habíamos visto con la prolongada
prolongación del tratado sobre misiles
start a ambos países van a hablar
también sobre ciberseguridad y ya no a
nivel de presidente sino a niveles más
bajos para tratar de encontrar algún
tipo de acuerdo aunque vladimir putin se
ha encargado de recordar que los
principales ataques del mayor número de
ataques en ciber ataques que ha recibido
eeuu no provienen precisamente de rusia
sino de suelo estadounidense en la
comparencia de putin hemos visto dónde
están las líneas rojas por ejemplo
en la oposición interna encarnada por
alexéi navalni y en el asunto y ucrania
respecto a ucrania putin ha frenado en
seco las aspiraciones respecto a las
últimas ofertas que se habían hecho en
las últimas peticiones que se habían
hecho durante los últimos días esa línea
para poder entrar de una vez a nadal
tenía dicho que no hay absolutamente
nada que negociar respecto a una
membresía de ucrania en la otan respecto
alexéi navalni ha respondido disparando
en todas direcciones criticando el sesgo
de la prensa internacional hablando de
las cárceles secretas de la cia hablando
de guantánamo pero lo más importante
señalando al líder opositor al líder
disidente aleccionaban y como
prácticamente algo parecido a un agente
de eeuu recordando que eeuu en algunos
documentos legislativos señala a rusia
como un enemigo como un adversario del
país y que por lo tanto aquellas
organizaciones rusas aquellas
plataformas aquellos movimientos
políticos como el de naval y que según
putin están recibiendo un apoyo por
parte de eeuu formarían parte del bando
estadounidense y que por eso tienen
razón las autoridades rusas enseñarlos
lo como un agente
extranjero y en perseguir legalmente lo
que considera putin que son violaciones
de la ley por parte de alexéi navalni
así que algunos avances en cuanto a
seguridad mundial y líneas rojas en
cuanto a lo que se refiere en la
vecindad al vecindario de rusia ucrania
y a la oposición interna